you anything you don't know but
I mean when you talk about
Patrick Mahomes a performance
tonight I'm in a lot of a lot
of talk about the homes as of
late right it's all about
what's wrong with Patrick
Mahomes you don't know what's
going on well Mahomes he knew
where you want to go with
the football all night long
didn't see him predetermined
decisions
because that's when the thing
all year where he doesn't go
through the Reeds like for the
first guy do the second guy oh
wait now it's the third guy
he's open hit it he's been
skipping reads he's been
impatient in the pocket which is
really hurt them a lot
during the year as far as
turning down pledge we go mad
if you
stay in the pocket your store
for your fast some reason you
left tonight and it's like he
knew what he was looking for
its knew what he was looking for
as he got the ball got to
stop every time and then you
just look comfortable with
in the pocket he wasn't looking
to run around make a play that
way stayed in there had his feet
in the ground and just
made a lot of really accurate
decisive throws consistently
through the game I think that's
a big thing that jumped out to
me guys get Chris one of
the interesting things that they
were doing with Travis Kelce
has never happened in Block
having him help out in pass
protection around and make
yourself
available for the screens are so
effective in the first half
while I think it helped because
you you chip you tip
the defensive end and then all
of a sudden they don't think
that
you're a part of the the play I
need you to get lost
and then you tip them and then
you turn around and you're wide
open you see Johnathan Abram
he's a strong safety plan and
then you put them in the
backfield he think that the run
and he comes up that's another
guy want to talk about Jonathan
April but yeah Kelsey is done a
terrific job of Chip and
helping out and of course the
run after the catch is
ridiculous we've seen so much
success rod with this to safety
look right playing the two deep
safeties and just take it away
the big
play from the Chiefs why was
that not the Raiders draft you
now you told me that
do why don't they do that
they're stubborn because they
say this is what we do we're not
going to change we're not
going to jump onto the bandwagon
like everybody else
but it works so that was the
thing you do me too cuz that's
when you
play a bass cover three with a
single safety high and you
don't blit if your front for
Crosby in the dark way if they
don't get put pressure you're
leaving your guys out to drive
now we have to do is dump it off
to the flats
make a gun this and it's 12 yd
and that's the thing that
I don't understand about Gus
Bradley's defense you have to
have variety you have to Blitz
you have his own precious you
have to do all those different
things you just can't sit back
and
Cover 3 there's no way you going
to the playoffs in back
plan cover three that Chris what
do I think he's exactly
right I mean I mean at some
point during the game tonight
yes when you see the art the
Chiefs are going to be patient
and Mahomes is going to throw
the underneath routes all night
long and got to do something to
change up that's for sure but
I'm sure the game plan Hey
listen we've all talked about
it Jack I heard your dad talking
about it a lot tonight
to write we seen the Patriots
took to Rodney's point I mean
that the Patriots the Chiefs
not be patient not be patient
all year long Mahomes looking
for deep shots people are open
underneath you know the Thea
patients in the office leaving
two turnovers interceptions
dropped passes and I think
that's the
big difference be solved them as
a team tonight didn't get
bored with like success okay
8-yard 7 yd 8 yd 7 yd so what
it wasn't a 60-yard touchdown
pass but because they were
surgical like that it started to
open up some other big
passes later
on in the football game and
maybe that's something we can
see here Rodney from these this
Chiefs offense as we go forward
in the missed opportunities like
when you think back on
the second half the Raiders had
some chances I get price
started with that Casey
hey we're we're both sitting
there together Mahomes just
threw it right to him but there
was more Jackson excetera what
went wrong when they did get
their chances for Vegas
Debbie I thought their car was
very conservative when he came
out and pass the ball but I mean
you look right here yeah
I'm just all over the place this
is an opportunity for them
to come up and make a play
and what is this this is a
penalty right match for
automatic but Casey he dropped
interception by Trayvon mirror
penalties eight penalties I mean
you can't win football
games like this and this is
opportunity for score get you
right back in the game DeSean
Jackson the guy that hadn't
played in a long time he comes
any fumbles it but this is this
is the thing
this is a real current thing
that happened in of course
their car he gets that but he
just keeps two or three up in
the air it's just crazy man in
the ball right they have those
two Alabama running backs coming
out of the backfield
that's
what they wanted to do where
Kansas City's been soft
stopping the run but they very
quickly came out of that given
that they were so far behind in
this game you get to feeling
like they really wanted to lean
on Josh Jacobs more not at all
really not at all because if you
want to run Josh Jacob cuz
it was a close game you run them
just like Darren Waller
the number one thing I say I
don't care who's defending
Darren Waller you have to get
him the ball he's 67 he
runs extremely fast he's a big
guy no quarterback or defensive
back on safety wants to cover
this guy and Derek are he backs
up and he doesn't look his way
and I'm like what kind of
offense
is this where you don't look
your very best player on
offense you don't even look this
way or back and that's
the reason why you see so many
sloppy place and he's their
leading receiver at tight end